non mais ça sérieusement mois la vidéo
initial qui a généré tout ce torrent de
haine m'a profondément choqué géré de la
même façon bon moi je suis chrétien
pratiquant quand frau mais sur france
inter chante jésus avait aussi sa majo
chapeau 6 à lui à coke
mais en fait le on a le droit de ne
choquer en france et c'est pas pour ça
que ça justifie que j'envoie à une fille
qui me choque one chanteur qui me choque
je vais à gorges et mais un seul
enterrés vivants c'est tout ce que je
dis je comprends que la vidéo ait choqué
des gens
maintenant la question à se poser c'est
pourquoi une seule religion en france
lorsqu'elle est critique et suscite ce
genre d'auto rang parce que le
christianisme a été nommé le
christianisme a été dense avec que
j'attends mais est-ce qu'il ya eu une
vidéo concernant une autre religion
peut-être s'est vu une victoire ils
avaient le choix sur france inter qu
d'une radio publique non mais attendez
c'est un parolier qui a été applaudi sur
une radio publique mais il n'a jamais
voulu et menaces à des parois du monde
c'est savoir aud'imat choqué qu est ce
qu on en savait que la main reçu des
menaces
mais moi je suis persuadé qu'ils ont la
réponse que si on en a reçus il l'aurait
fait état avant moi je vous dis là
puisse dire c'est qu'il n'a pas reçues
100 milles de là vous dites moi je pense
qu'il en a reçu à est la même partout
parce que ça n'avait rien à voir
c'était une personne qui faisait une
parodie alors ils parodient les landais
mais bon voilà les régler quel est le
point commun entre mille à eric zemmour
zineb el rhazoui etc enfin il y en a que
sincèrement c'est quoi le point commun
je voulais vous protège les données hier
ils sont tous ceux protection policière
d'accord ils sont menacés en permanence
24 24 et ses obligés l'imam chalghoumi
même chose parce que lui prône à voir si
vous voulez moi la frette prof m
quel que soit le sujet vous déroulez
toujours la même chose on a merdé
s'évacueront l'armée oui mais demain je
vais parler de rodger federer va en
sortir
oui non mais là le problème on prend la
mouche sur la vidéo constat cela
je trouve que là c'est la démonstration
justement on est on est en train de
tomber dans le piège qui nous est tendu
c'est à dire on utilise une jeune femme
qui a eu des propos qui sont ridicules
déplacer et ça crée une réaction sociale
qui en pour une partie d'entre elles
extrêmement déplacée est grave très bien
et à partir de là en fait à partir de
cette jeune fille qui n'aurait jamais dû
sortir de l'anonymat qu'ils auraient dû
être protégé et points et s'assurer que
les choses se calment est on en a fait
une affaire nationale où on commence à
avoir des débats atroces sur les
questions religieuses sur la question de
qui et courage de soyaux général oui
alors maison mais ça profite à quelqu'un
c'est en fait il ya des gens car j'ai
antalis et a fermé de la télé confie
t-il fait monter dans les médias
j'aurais dit entend les autres héros je
suis fini là dessus mais juste mancini a
dit ce qui fait que mon client encore
une fois ce qui est catholique donc ça
n'a rien à voir avec une question de
religion et bien sûr aux teams sont en
garde à vue perquisitionné
mais on en 48 accusé infirmé et
aujourd'hui au tribunal est resté coi
l'état c'est moi qui l'a mis sur les
rails a dit m là il a dit il j'ai eu dix
ans des panneaux fleurissent est
important mais c'est important de vous
dire il a il a dit qu'elle avait une
sexualité qui n'était pas dirigée non il
n'y a pas de menace d'ailleurs il n'est
pas poursuivi pour menaces pas
poursuivre mais pour moi je suis
fortement que l'échantillon est
représentatif c'est justement dans la
news il n'est en rien représentatif des
100 milliards en fait jean mais c'est en
plus il dit exactement ce que la plupart
des gens disent ici et il veut quand
même ce mec contre nous et ambitionnant
gens mais ça c'est parce qu'il fait ou
devriez dénoncé l'impuissance de ce
gouvernement par rapport au terrorisme
par rapport à la qualité
non messieurs la pêche et le fait qu'ils
utilisent ce genre d'affaires la dette
qu'ils utilisent ce genre d'affaires est
leur appui science mais c'est 50 mais je
vais vous dire un truc que vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure
d'instrumentalisation mais qui a
effectivement dénoncer cette affaire
parce que je vais vous dire mais la
gauche l'extrême gauche la france est
soumise à la croissance y est la france
est soumise le parti socialiste du
politique à la fois qu'ils auraient été
aux abonnés absents mais genre que c'est
la honte comme les gens